[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers in my friends
this is guns in here and welcome to my
eighth episode of queen trap sack lines
in this episode I'm going to show you
one of the extraordinary counter trap in
the English defense where black
sacrificed the Queen on the 12th move of
the game now the good point I like about
this opening is you can apply it against
both d4 and c4 so let's say if you open
and start with d4 then you can continue
with c6 and in this game white plays c4
where black replies with b6 ok we have
d4 transposing back into the Queen's
pawn game black plays a six and now one
of the popular choice by White Knight to
f3
Bishop to b7 by black and if you check
this position in online database here
the highest Lee played movies g3 which
has a clear intention to transpose the
game back to the Catalan opening as a
proper English defense player black
should continue with this thematic move
Bishop captures f3 the point is when
white recapture yes indeed black has
given up the bishop pair but in return
he get some structural weaknesses on the
White King side and in a long run black
can argue that they are more sufficient
to create a full point okay now it's
time to grab the center so black plays
d5 and accordingly why try to put the
pressure on the D Phi square with Knight
to c3 and as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows white has a
very effective plan such
Queen to b3 f4 bishop to g2 and put lot
of pressure on the D Phi square here
black has tried various responses but
I'm going to propose this tricky mu D
capture c4 well at first sight this
looks so stupid right
because free-of-charge white bishop has
been developed but I guess at this point
both the players has their own drone as
a black you have some the structural
weaknesses which you can easily aiming
for in the middle game where on the
counter part white has not only obtained
the bishop pair but he has a lead in
peace development and on top of
everything right now White has a simple
thread to play the moon D Phi and get
rid of his isolated Queen pole now as a
black obviously you cannot allow this so
traumatic movies c6 controlling the D
Phi square but guess watch White says
nope sweetie I'm going to play the moon
D Phi anyways the big point is it
doesn't matter how we were black capture
on D Phi let's say in this game
black continued vite he kept us D Phi
and then white deliver this nasty punch
nightcap just defy back obviously you
cannot take this night the simple reason
is after C captors D Phi Queen captures
D Phi attacking to soft sports and if
black exchange the Queen then after
Bishop captures D Phi black will lose
the exchange and in fact the game
so that is right out of the equation and
if black cannot capture this night then
don't you think white has a huge
advantage
well of course right why this better in
this position but here comes the tricky
part as black is going to continue with
this super surprising move Knight to e7
afterwards it is white who has to be
very careful and the big time trap is
set right here there's a funny story
associate when first time this position
happened on the board Belak who is the
in-charge of the white piece his
opponent played the move Knight to e7
and offered him the draw where Belak
stare at his opponent and say from the
inside how you get nuts can't you see
your queen is losing and you offering me
a draw completely ridiculous well
naturally that will be the reaction of
many of your opponent as the eyes will
literally lit up after they see this
continuation which Vince the black queen
with Knight to f6 check the most amazing
part about this mortar is if you check
this position in online database there
are 10 games played with exactly the
same position including seven are the
master games where here black responses
force black has to capture this night
afterwards white will continue with this
obvious move the chef captures f7 chat
and after King takes f7 you can see
easily black queen is unprotected and
white will simply snap of it
so now if you count the material at this
point white has a queen for two nights
and upon which is generally not a good
compensation for the black
but as happened in chess some positions
are very special and this is one of them
now before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a sequence where
mystery behind this whole position can
be revealed okay are you ready did you
find this fast accurate move Knight to
d5 Black has a very cunning idea he
wants to play Bishop to b4 check and
then nabbing the White Queen something
which white need to pay attention
immediately here it doesn't matter
whether white continue with Bishop to d2
or castle on the King side both will be
treated equally let's say in this game
Belak continue with castle on the Kings
side
afterwards black revealed his nasty idea
Bishop to g7 surprisingly enough here
White Queen has the only space to go
namely Queen to d6 but before we look at
it the important point I like to
highlight here that if white goes for
this transaction Queen captures a shade
then after the simple move Bishop
captures a shade black obtained tonight
against rook and upon which is generally
a good trade for the black and s
confirmed by the professional engine
this position is slightly better for the
black but the most important question is
many of you will ask well if there is a
1 square then why can't you just go
there Queen to d6 what else well here
comes the cue point and I hope you have
seen it yup the devastating move Bishop
to afraid attacking the Queen and if you
carefully look at this
position the White Queen has once again
only space to hide namely Queen to d8
and after that yup we have the forcing
draw on the board with Bishop to g7
Queen to d6 and now Bishop we have
failed confirms the threefold repetition
what a wonderful trap and game that's it
guys I hope you enjoy and learn this
amazing Queen sacrifice line in the
English defense remember at this point
play the move Knight to e7 and tease
your opponent with asking a draw and I
bet many of your opponent just like veal
ad play the move Knight to f6 thinking
that they are going to win your queen
and in fact the game but after Knight to
d5
it is only white who get the room
shocked in the two now in practice if
you meet a hiring opponent then this
line is definitely worth trying as from
the opening it's pretty much forced and
just like Belak and other grandmasters
many of your opponent will fall into
this and you will get some healthy
points thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care